for my next guest my buddy my pro
football hall of famer
my nfl gameday morning compadre
it's the other version michael irvin
here on the rich eisen show
how are you michael rich
i am stupendous
stupendous i mean i'm better than
splendid
uh i'm better than super i am
stupendous i'm coming out with words
yesterday all together though rich this
must have been a great show for you guys
today
because yes the anthony davis shot you
know last session
the cam newton tackle last second
i mean the overtime kansas city chiefs
game
last second and of course the granddaddy
of them all oh wow which is america's
team
coming back 20 down at the top
of the game it was insane
what a great day what a great day i mean
so much so
that um you know we've hardly touched
upon anthony davis's
last second shot which we will uh that's
why we got another hour and a half a
runway here
and we did you know slightly touch upon
uh justin herbert
getting that emergency start and almost
beating the chiefs who
needed overtime and three swings at the
leg from
50 yards out from there from their place
kicker to win but i guess let's
let's settle in on dallas why i mean i
guess
you know there's no pictures in the
standings but there's no concern
out of you it's all superpendus when it
comes to the dallas cowboys
michael no no no there are concerns i'll
start worried about the concerns on
wednesday when we start working
on the next on wednesday when we start
working on next week but right now
given the alternative where it was i
watched that whole game rich i stood up
in front of the tv i couldn't even sit
down
i tweeted earlier what is this mess up
on my tv
you see i didn't know i didn't know what
that was
what was going on i was like oh my god a
game of this magnitude and this
how they come not even prepared where
guys punching the ball out
and okay and you saw him do it to one
dude now you should be making love
to this football when you get it don't
you ever let her leave your arms
you show him and you gonna let him punch
your ball right back out of your arm
oh it was insane man it was insane
but but but but but i say this rich
the way that game went down
may be the difference of all even if the
cowboys went in
and put up 40 points and beat it hadn't
made all those turnovers
and say since they gave them 20 it would
have been 40 to 29
uh or 40 to 19. you know instead of 40
to 39 because the cowboys gave them 20
points on the top even though
that that offense was moving up and down
on the field on defense they go and beat
the 40 29
it's not the same thing as beating them
40 to 39
after you spotted them 20 points a game
like this
can can perpetuate you in the greater
things
for the rest of the season i mean jack
34 47 450 yards
i mean three touchdowns uh that that is
a significant that is a significant
um stat lines three three runs as well i
mean like that that
is it's he accounted for four touchdowns
um michael so right is this
is this um is this it i mean is this the
moment that we are gonna start talking
about dak like
lamar and kyler and and and patrick
on the show yesterday we talked about
that wow when we asked what
okay what do we need what does that need
to do with it i said i'm putting it all
on that
it's all on that i knew atlanta's
offense
was going up and down the field i was i
i had to put the pressure
on that came back and said i'm going to
have six receivers go over 100 because
those three guys they had played great
and they did play great again
can't believe judeo missed that
touchdown off that touchdown but i know
i i guarantee i know what was happening
with that wow
hold on what what was what was happening
with that one i'm sure [ __ ] fantastic
things see see you're not getting bald
that ball wasn't thrown from his
quarterback
and the ball thrones balls have
different spins on him man
and because you're watching and when he
when he looked up when he looked up
he was fading away he started fading
away why is he fading away
and this is what guys do when you look
up sometimes and that ball get lost
in the stadium or get lost in the lights
you're kind of fading because you don't
know which way it goes which way
and you're waiting on it to show again
and then you reach your hands out and
grab it
i say he must have lost that ball that's
the only reason
he was fading away he was fading away to
give himself
much many more areas to catch because
the ball's on the other side
i can see that and run to it as opposed
to spin around and have to catch it on
the other side
so you start fading when you lose it in
the lights
and then when it drops out the light you
try to grab it and snatch it but
but whatever happened all right no i
don't
wish for a man dropping balls but that
didn't happen
i was quite pleased right please i love
julio but i was quite frustrated
because that would have put a nail in
the car what do you think is going on in
the atlanta locker room today
what's happening today oh my god yeah oh
my god but
that that it's total shock total shock
because you already felt the pain
with that when when you lost that super
bowl and you
said to yourself each man when you went
back in that locker room
and looked at each other looked in each
other's eyes you said this would never
happen again i guarantee you'll never
happen again
it just happened again you know granted
it's not a superpose
of course but it just happened again and
i guarantee you
they're sitting in there like oh my god
and it
and here is another one of those games
that that's one of those games
that when you go home when you get back
home and they get back to atlanta
there's no one falling asleep the only
way you get rest
is by pass out there is no voluntary
fall in the sleep
this must be the pass out because your
mind
is not going to let you stop thinking
about what you just did and how you just
let that game get away
and oh my god we're only two in the seat
your mind won't let you stop
so the only way to sleep is is to pass
out that means
you know pass me a vodka cranberry and
when you see this we get halfway past
another one
until the pass out let me get some rest
that way because
that's the only way you calm your mind
michael irvin here on the rich eisen
show
um and i imagine i i i've never really
asked you this question i don't know
what it would have come up but
i imagine you've spent some time on a
hands team uh
in your career um and what the hell
was atlanta thinking of watching that
ball spin
for as long as they watched it spin did
they think it wasn't going to go the
10-yard so
they could just like it was like a bunt
that they thought was gonna go foul
and it stayed fair i mean don't they
know that you could jump on that ball at
any point in time you don't have to wait
for it to travel 10 yards i mean what
was that about
i mean seriously you saw 81 all of them
like
back up don't touch it like why why
like like go grab it when they were
doing it i i promise you and i love them
you know i love them
i love them but i i surely say oh my god
this is a leonlette moment oh my god
like they they don't know the rules
instead of i don't care if you kick that
ball out of bounds
i don't care what you do you you you
just get
why are you getting away from it you
have from zero
to 9.9 yards
because they gonna jump on it you got
all that time
and the ball was going slow it wasn't
like it was a wiggle like a bounce right
so
you're afraid to jump on a bounce
because you don't know
if you're gonna grab it or if it's going
to bounce out of your hand when the ball
spinning on the ground like that
you crawl around it you could have done
that at five yards right you could have
done it at six yards
could have done it but they were backing
everybody up and that thing just kept
on spinning and then it hit a little
turn and oh my god i just say
man rich i
i almost almost blew out my home office
because
and all these cameras in here yeah i was
falling tripping all over the cameras
because i was going crazy i could it was
insane man that
that was a great great comeback i'm
telling you
that i believe will prepare all the
cowboys this whole season michael irvin
a few more minutes left with him here on
the rich hasn't show another
uh item that we discussed at length
during nfl game name morning the
four-hour pregame
uh on nfl network um on sunday
was you saying cam's gonna have to throw
it he's gonna have to throw it at some
point and we were
and and you know everyone agreed uh but
it was infused with
some doubt wondering how cam will look
in this office
he was buddy oh my god did he throw it
um on sunday night uh he's back correct
like this is super cam
is shown up in new england we've we we
don't need to
wonder correct that's official yeah yeah
yeah
the best cam is shown has shown up it is
who
that's the guy that showed up in new
england and and i love what i heard
yesterday
you know i heard where they were asking
him about he said
what drew him there and this is
brilliant
because it's real what drew him there
was not the idea
of replacing tom brady but the idea
of playing would be a belichick a
playing for bill belichick
like i just got to go get that guy let
me go get that guy
that guy right there he has the midas
touch
he can fix everything fix anything i i
just got to get to that guy
and and and that guy would bring the
best out and and
on his instagrams it was all oh i don't
believe you don't believe you don't
believe
and then he comes to new england and
they make him a captain so you knew
you knew they were so old they believe
in me in new england
in new england and i'm going to show
them how much i appreciate it by
throwing my body
around everywhere now how long that will
last
i don't know but yeah the real cam
he's back man and and they look good
that was a great game last night amazing
that was a great game
that was great uh and and nikhil harris
showed up
i mean i i knew i i talked about that i
said
you know cam kim's going to go outside
in the caribbean even if he couldn't get
open
on the first turn he's going to have two
three more turns
as cam moves around and can get him the
ball and
i mean he showed up i mean julian adam
we're used to what he does but for
nikhil harry to show up like that that
was big
d.k metcalf though too i i i know you
love big physical receivers i mean and
with the defensive player of the year
reigning defensive player of the year
basically traveling with him
the entire night um there was quite a
battle i think you you even
uh might have tweeted about it with him
and gilmore on the sidelines better
believe i did because you saw
that he was not that bored with having
it rich
he wasn't having it they tell the truth
to shame the devil
he was not having uh
gilmore was trying to intimidate him he
was trying to bully him
i'm a bully this young guy i got him you
know he's a big guy but probably
soft but dk wasn't soft at all
i saw it in gilmore's eyes like this is
a big
joker i've seen that look at his eyes
before
right i know man and and and he was just
one of five guys who caught touchdown
passes from russell wilson who's really
making it work so
the next team that's got russell wilson
in front of them next week has their
hands full oh wait a minute
oh boy it's your cowboys
now i know you're like i'll wait till
wednesday to try and figure out what the
problems are
now now i'm putting two together uh-huh
but this game is what i'm talking about
can't propel you when you do this you
can carry this
the aroma of coming back stays
in your nostrils all year long so when
you go to seattle
and you're down hey we've been here
before let's go
we're ready for all we got to do is
believe we need that little belief you
hear
that little belief will dictate that
effort i
always thought i hope that the whole
dictating effort that little belief
will give more effort from them and give
them a chance and remember now
the 12 aren't there oh yes no i know
i know and so so we're talking about let
russ cook but you've got the aroma of
comeback
in your nostrils from week two yes and
it lingers
the aroma likes one of those smells in
your kitchen you can't
you open up the windows you don't want
to get rid of that aroma you gotta
you just let that marinate in the
nostril and the nose gate
you let that marinade in your nose gate
and let it travel to your heart gate
right michael in in a sense in a sensual
sense where what i mean by that not
being sexual in any way but i'm saying
it will turn on the scent of the
comeback
so it it pushed it puts your senses back
on oh we can
we can come back from this so so that
aroma stays with you
and they weren't needed they will need
that
the pheromone of comeback is on the
dallas cowboys
i love it how do you think that thing
happened when we called people to
cardiac kids
or or listen denver's going through it
right now
you don't think denver's in the locker
room saying we've been here before
we've been here before nothing all the
lakers fans yes what they saying
we've been here before because the aroma
is still
it's in them they know that that's what
they're going to try to use to pull back
on the lakers
it's there that's what i'm telling you i
like it
so it's it's not just football it's any
sport it goes to any sport the aroma
oh this is fantastic well those kind of
come back
you do two series back-to-back you come
back from 3-1 with nobody
that kind of come back right that's what
i'm talking about that that stays with
you for
for a while all right before i let you
go ask the poll question of michael
irvin
chris brockman go for it all right irv
who is in the most
trouble after two weeks eagles falcons
texans 49ers you choose one
that's right boy eagles falcons texans
49ers when i was getting killed back now
even though they lost so much on defense
that's going to hurt but they'll be in a
battle
texas man i'm worried about the eagles
i'm worried about the cowboys offensive
line i'm worried about the eagles
also but i i i would probably lean
towards
man that's a tough one though that's a
tough one reaction that's what we need i
want to say houston just because they're
seeing what deandre hopkins is doing
right he went in nothing hopefully you
know what to say
but but if if boy
it's going to be hard for the san fran
to get back in it now that they've lost
big boss and i just said yesterday
that i thought they would be fine but
you lose nick and solomon thomas
and we don't know what's going on with
quarterback yet and
with the way they look in the west
everybody then
then that that's going to be tough
that's that's in trouble right michael
has settled on the 49ers the only
non-o and 2 team in this choice what is
what are the results as they currently
stand chris
eagles lead the way right now guys 41
49ers 27
yeah i mean uh wence did not look good
yesterday
again michael he did not
he did not he did not and and
and now but but but i but i'm
the only thing there is if he doesn't
look good again next week
do we see jaylen hurt should we you see
what i'm saying and then
and and then that poll would be right
because now
we got a collapse over there in the
structure of what what's going on
because if jane earth's come in and
plays well
uh oh oh oh then then yeah that would be
certainly an issue well i gotta tell you
man it's they're welcoming
joey burrow in okay so um
a second straight first overall
selection but the one that they just
lost to is the one who's connected to
wence because the rams chose him
over wence in the same draft but here
comes cincinnati
and then they're at san francisco for a
sunday nighter
and you know i i i know they just paid
once
and it's very difficult to sit here and
say that that he's done that might be a
very
significant overreaction but what we're
seeing
from the run past threat quarterbacks
that cam is now
you know back at the very top you have
to say
um jalen hurts has to be a consideration
you gotta for a kid who also has that
gumption
that that that it fact he's got the
aroma
you know what i mean he's got that right
he has some money
yes i'm with him he has something with
me and that's what i'm talking about
and rich and you know
listen you know those philly fans
if that guy comes in and they win two
games in a row
or anything like that oh my god see ya
that's why i might choose philadelphia
too cause they do have san francisco
uh after cincinnati at pittsburgh home
for baltimore
and certainly with the the cowboys
playing the way that they're suddenly
playing after
having that one thing happen very good
for them yesterday
um look out got to keep pace right yeah
yeah they could they could there are a
lot there's a lot that can go on there
that can uh they can further the issue
you know and losing is going to amplify
all of it
all of it oh yeah by the way last thing
for you dion's the head coach of jackson
state it's official what do you think
now it's official and i'm so happy for
him i already
announced it on his podcast uh i i was
going to tweet out congratulations to
him because i know
listen man i've been around dion a long
time man you know
how important it is how important those
kids are to him
so to get an opportunity to get his foot
in the door
um and be a head coach at the college
level
and i'm sure he you know he's got
aspirations to move up
but but yeah that's a great start for
him and and i think he'll do well
because i think he'll do well in
recruiting you know oh no
i'm playing i played for dion sanders
damn straight i want to say that no
question about it and you know
all the defensive backs there will know
how to arm bar somebody in a very
crucial championship game
right michael yes they will yes they
will know how to
know how to get away with it yeah i just
said to chief
you have to get away with it yes that's
like that's what deion sanders
and jaylen ramsey type people do they
offer florida state
they're over florida state love you you
know love you michael irvin
great spot as always all right buddy
we'll see you soon all right good talk
right back
it's michael over hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here